pas tellement longtemps avec ma soeur et
mon frère on fouillait dans des vieux
souvenirs on est tombés sur des lettres
de notre père de papa les dettes des
années 30 qu'il écrivait à sa mère lors
qu'ils étaient donc été pensionnaire au
collège et c'était des histoires du
quotidien tout simple j'ai hâte un
examen j'aurai besoin d'un peu de sous
pourrais-tu m'envoyer tel chandail ce
genre de petites choses là serge giguère
quétin mon invité aujourd'hui qui est un
documentariste les ailes du québec
une de nos figures majeures ici a
retrouvé des lettres de sa mère des
années 50 c'est à linverse de mon
histoire mes sujets bonjour aux jambes
est l'essence même de ce film là que
vous venez que vous présentez qui sort
ces jours-ci la wii lettre de ma mère
c'est des mots de cette dame écrite des
mots écrits sur la table de cuisine avec
ses baies d'écriture tout précise à ses
enfants un peu partout notamment et
surtout à son ami qui était le sien oui
comment est née l'idée de plonger dans
de plonger là dedans ça c'est très
agréable à fin mai d'en faire un film à
l'idée d'en faire un film ça mûrit train
qui ne m'a pas ce que moi j'étais pas au
courant des led de ma main avant fin
2006 2007
c'est venu comme ça et quelqu'un dans
une réunion de famille qui se passait
chez mon frère a aidé qui est allé
fouiller puis était et oignons ramener
les lettres qu'ils étaient dans une
boîte de chaussures d'un choc on a
ressorti les lettres comme la marche on
y voit des photos
et puis l1 on a eu chaud un peu puis on
ne rit on a vu ce qu'était notre par
rapport à tel sujet tel autre et puis ça
mûrit tranquillement mais quelle vue je
fais des films documentaires
man et judith est un sujet l'eau pour
faire un film mais jusqu'à passer les
fêtes un lien d'ailleurs avec le tout
premier
ouais le faire à la maison ouais ouais
avec vous aimeriez vous avez une
surimposition de cameron ouais ça
c'était moi quand j'avais cheveux bruns
avec des moustaches aussi et c'était six
mois avant son décès et tétouan plein
d'énergie soldats oui mais on savait
très malade profondément et puis calé
j'ai fait ce cumul un peu comme en
urgence moi je travaille à merveille à
cette époque là à l'office national du
film comme plus justes
j'étais insiste un caméraman le jeu donc
je faisais mes premières armes depuis
quelques années dans la caméra aussi
belge est le premier film qu'est ce que
j'ai fait j'ai emprunté au jour pour le
jour de l'an à emprunter les caméras le
hénaff y avait avait comme une lie
d'artisanat complet
et puis là c'est comme ça avec cet
équipement l'eau puis mon petit frère
tetro au sens en lui lui montre comment
comment marche le magnétophone les
professionnels tch
et puis on s'installe dès 7 heures du
matin à onze ans de choix puis on filme
simplement tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui au jour donnant pas beaucoup
les entrées des sorties ma mère qui
arrête pas là oui et qui fit donc pas
d'entrevue comme tel mais juste
simplement l'espèce de deux témoignages
de ce qu'ils sont dans la vie de tous
les jours et vous avez récupéré de ses
images la lettre de hu est piégé jeudi
tout le temps que le film délai de ma
mère là je pense que ce film là à mais
j'en fait en 1961 six mois 20 qu'avec
elle meurt un peu film fait en urgence
la cij avait pas eu ces images le dell
vivant je sais pas si j'aurais eu un
espèce de moteur assez fort je savais
des photos puis des narrations puis
javel sur le plus sa voix comme tel sans
son banc des tacles segment télécoms
comme l'énergie cas là je suppose que
réduit autant de
le plaisir ou de l'énergie pour boire
faire mon mon dernier film qui s'appelle
de ma mère effectivement plaisir
coupable
oui moi je
c'était le défi lot par rapport à
d'autres faits moi ce cas tu as des
personnages vivent ces deux de récré
justement d'espèces de dramatique où est
ce que tu peux faire rayer par moments
alors que ce que je fais je fais de la
pixilation avec les photos jeux java
gage quelqu'un pour m'aider à faire ça
ensuite je fais je prends une photo de
sam et puis je la gabegie chaque
personnage devient réel les jours sauf
des cartons et puis je les fait évoluer
un pitch nation dans le film et je mets
aussi des archives un peu de l'époque lé
puis je fais des entrevues avec mes
frères et s'appuient jeu les confronte
avec les lettres
donc c'est un espèce de bricolage comme
tel je me suis filmé en train de faire
mais m'aider car ces juges public un
accessoire est ce que tu vas faire si tu
vois personne c'est moi qui ai fait on
complète map c'est ça donnera le
résultat que ça donne parce que je pars
un professionnel du décor là mais j'aime
jamais se dire je fais quelque chose
dans mon atelier
et puis comment comme on paie un peu
comme ma mère je dis tout le temps en
effet 2 avec deux issus de la ruralité
vous
ouais c'est ça paul et la
débrouillardise aussi fâché de faire des
choses avec à rien puis moi j'étais
habillée par ma mère jusqu'à l'âge de 7
ans c'est à nous nous confectionnait
tous nos habits jeune couturière alors
perles
puis quand j'ai un de mes charges était
aujourd'hui vivent encore sur l'iphone à
à goal ray pour
réunir chambre était comme ça serge très
entreprenante
sergey vous êtes le 15e de 16 enfants
ouais le chef des chances de 16
naissances oui pardon et votre frère
aîné qui a été le destinataire de la
grande partie de ces lettres là parce
que partie parce que parce qu'ils
voulaient faire un prêtre
voilà c'est ça lui voue le confronter au
départ aussi ben je le comprends oui
mais pas tellement note pas dans un sens
d'agressivité ou quoi qui sonne juste
sans cette lettre là ça voulait dire
quoi à tel moment ça ça te fait quoi ça
pourquoi de recevoir ça oui c'est ça lui
ça lui donnait un image in this il dit
d'un film ça lui donnait une image de ce
comme la mère vivait au quotidien avec
toute la trame et d'enfin qu'elle avait
ces suppositions ça m'a été révélé par
les lettres que moi même lui il devenait
le confident de frime
si alain le premier pilote il va faire
hurler des années c'est 45 50
la religion catholique se serait fait
que le legault dans ta femme est il le
plus vu qui veut devenir paraître ça
devient comme temps qu'on fait ça et
c'était pénible et beaucoup de sol avec
un juge pouvait pas passer à côté de ces
éléments là puis il se rendre à port
jusqu'à la porte est régi large un peu
avant mais toute sa vie était très
catholique de djerba mais sont encore 1
87 ans a fait don d'une famille très
traditionnel il ya des malheurs qui sont
propres à cette époque l'est une
chronique des papes tu ma mère par deux
enfin mais pas n'importe comment
le même choix contaminé 137g pas
d'antibiotiques et puis bon c'est que
piano n 1 une manade au travail de sape
et enceinte d'un autre piste est à la
bourre pont aven quinzaine d'années
après à sa fille
j'aurais aimé mieux que tu qu'à ce
moment là des perdre et je pensais mais
je veux sauver les deux sens la ccc
force et c'est comme une espèce de
sentiment de culpabilité qui était pas
capable de deux d'accepter seul sait
c'est une somme de l'image que j'en ai
vu à regarder ce fait qui était une
lumière incroyable dans une période de
grande noirceur de difficultés de vie
aussi des trois emplois de papa pour
arriver à vivre
et puis à lui et des beaucoup de gens
ouais je pense que j'ai des ménages puis
bon il souhaitait tout annonce est une
jeune femme moi je fais pas des films
avec des méthodes et vedette en général
mais je fais des comme disait le nom
comme neuf
comment pdg le cd ça vous change une
émission sur les remarquables oubliés
moi j'adore ça mais c'est un peu comme
ma mère c'est à le fait le québec
elle a fait 16 enfin le eu des jets des
accouchements à es16 enfin 22 heures
c'est comme ces quelque chose à 800
c'est quelque chose est fait elle voit
la ccc témoigné je n'ai pas que tu un
constat moi j'ai pas de la nostalgie de
d'achat en été chanceux les deux
derniers d'arrivée avec le rapport
parent pu leur les écoles avec les
portions les bourses pelé
les pins pour étudier et puis j'en ai
profité
mais mes frères et sa lavalas ce qui en
fait le septième année est en fait 36
métiers 36 misère et puis ils sont
débrouillés mais il y aurait pu être des
artistes l'oeil aladin qui avaient
énormément de talent mais chez nous que
chez qu'avais je pense il y avait
inscrit
l'enveloppé du grolier pim quand j'étais
12 500 rentes seraient publiés avant
diable comme comme sacré temps elle a
acheté le premier tourne disque le
portatif
c'est ce que j'ai vu chez nous c'est et
puis l'allemagne du peuple cubain au
législateur de la terre de chez nous
puis mézin la mexa de la tva ce filtre
votre personnage ça transcende le fait
d'être votre mère c'est ouais tu ne mets
ça pourrait s'appliquer ces histoires là
on peut les voir dans certaines
communautés en afrique on y voit des
amérindiens
on les voit dans les communautés amish
et j'en passe belge je te fais quelque
chose qui qui m'a été aussi révélé avec
les quelques projections qui ont eu
dernièrement j'ai eu une première
critique dans un journal une critique de
cinéma par maghrébins puis il ya le
terme console wii c'est la mer nous
révélant sa main chez la mère
universelle dernière le choc d'une autre
projection une amie innu t elle l est d
un chef rebelle est né l'a bien vu
maintenant à montréal a choqué des
autochtones l'emploi des autochtones à
montréal
et puis sa mère est encore ou achat puis
à gillot le faudrait que je fasse un
film sur l'histoire c'est ma grand mère
tout ça puis c est tout
et puis j'en ai je suis blanc elle est
vraiment lorencei nous paie vraiment les
tindouf et tout mais je trouve est un
beau témoignage il ya quelque chose là
qu'il avait touché dans cette espèce de
deux regards de la mer c'est un film qui
se regarde à la vitesse de la plume qui
se promènent sur la feuille de papier
vous êtes obligés de vous êtes bon
boulot les lettres de ma mère de serge
giguère et il prend l'affiché
aujourd'hui en fait cette semaine si oui
sous peu sous peu un peu partout pays
allait me aller voir ces deux belles
tendresse à giguère merci beaucoup
ben vous remercie beaucoup se démarque
tout bonne journée